une idylle la parole est à monsieur jean
françois lamour
oui merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la défense monsieur le
ministre
l'ennemi n'est pas un ennemi de la
france c'est un ennemi de l'europe voilà
en ces termes que le président de la
république trois jours après les
événements les attentats de novembre
dernier
on a appelé à la solidarité militaires
des pays de l'union avant de s'engager
dans une tournée des capitales
européennes
monsieur minier dont on se demande
aujourd'hui à quoi elle a bien pu servir
en effet quatre mois après cette
déclaration d'intention notre pays reste
en première ligne au sahel dans la lutte
contre les groupes armés terroristes
3500 soldats français sont ainsi engagés
dans la force barkan je tiens à saluer
leur professionnalisme et leur courage
dans des conditions qui mettent à rude
épreuve les hommes et les matériels au
monsieur le ministre sur le terrain
la minus ma peine à remplir sa mission
est aujourd'hui essentiellement
concentrée à sa propre sécurité et la
contribution européenne je l'a qualifié
d' anecdotique un peu de logique un peu
de logistique dans le domaine du
transport et du var et du ravitaillement
mais également dans la formation de fait
la france reste en première ligne
seul pour mener à bien une mission qui
est à la fois indispensable et difficile
la france est seule alors que les
terroristes ont montré vient de montrer
leur capacité à frapper en profondeur
comme c'est le cas en côte d'ivoire
dimanche dernier la france est seule
alors que l'expansion de dèche en libye
rend encore plus difficile la
stabilisation des pays du sahel
la france est seule alors qu'elle doit
maintenir dans le cadre de l'opération
sentinelle 7000 soldats sur notre
territoire national où on sait elle
subit une pression sans précédent des
groupes islamistes
alors messieurs nice où sont les
promesses du 16 novembre où on est cette
solidarité européenne invoquer
solennellement devant le conte
merci le président rappelant les temps
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
la défense monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député jean françois lamour
merci de cette question qui me permet de
faire le point sur la mise en oeuvre de
la vocation qu'avait initié le président
de la république à l'article 42 7 du
traité de lisbonne indiquant la
nécessité d'une solidarité européenne
lorsqu'il y a un cas d'agressions à
l'égard d'un des pays membres nous avons
fait le point avec mes collègues
ministres de la défense il ya quelques
jours et les résultats ne sont pas ceux
que vous indiquez peut-être ne sont-ils
pas assez connu et donc du coup je vais
me permette de voulait commenter et de
vous les expliquer d'abord en ce qui
concerne le levant l'irak et la syrie
depuis la vocation de l'article 42 7
la grande-bretagne et les néerlandais
ont décidé de frapper sur la syrie ce
qui n'était pas le cas auparavant
et ils l'ont fait en vertu de cette
incitation par ailleurs toujours en irak
et en syrie
lorsque le charles de gaulle a mené sa
mission il vient de rentrer il était
accompagné d'une frégate belge une
frégate allemande d'une frégate
britannique ce qui compensait elle après
la présence française par ailleurs les
italiens les allemands et les
néerlandais ont décidé de renforcer leur
mission de formation en irak et en syrie
en ce qui concerne le mali et en ce qui
concerne la bande sahélo saharienne
je vous rappelle mais vous le devez le
savoir que l'allemagne a décidé de
diligenter 650 militaires en somalie à
la fois pour renforcer la minus mas qui
n'est pas en banque et aussi la mission
de l'union européenne l'allemagne est
suivi dans ce dans cette direction par
les belges par les roumains par les
danois par les suédois et par les pays
baltes ils se sont tous mobilisés pour
faire en sorte que la mission des
nations unies et de l'union européenne
puisse être renforcées dans les jours
qui viennent par ailleurs en
centrafrique vers visiom candidature
yeux sont 28